- [Host] I think dumplings are amazing
because everyone loves it.
If you say dumping, everyone's faces will light up.
- Hi, I'm Daniel and I'm making mandu today.
Mandu is a Korean-style dumpling, it's similar...
It's the Korean version
of what a lot of Americans know as pot stickers.
You know, I'm not entirely sure why they do use tofu.
I actually didn't realize
that most other cultures don't use tofu.
As for why you have to extract the water, if you don't,
it will make the mandu too watery.
I got the basic recipe from my mom.
My mom actually eyeballs most of the spices and what not,
so I had to get more exact specifications online.
It's pretty rare to make mandu these days
unless it's for Korean New Years,
and even then me and my mom haven't made it in a while.
After finding out that I made it for this video,
she actually wants to restart the tradition
of making it for New Years again.
True story.
I use egg and water because it helps the skin stick better.
For some reason,
when I just use water, it never seems to stick.
I don't know what everyone else's secret is.
It just doesn't work for me.
Growing up Korean-American, especially 'cause I'm only half,
was definitely a little bit confusing,
but one of the easiest ways to connect with Korean culture
and with my mom was always through food.
Making mandu is one of the more fun ways
to connect with my Korean heritage.
Food in general has always been one of the easiest ways
for me and my mom to connect,
which was very important for her
and ultimately very important for me
to help me understand my heritage
and where my mom came from.
- Hi, my name is Lisa,
and today I'm going to be making guotie.
Guotie are Chinese dumplings otherwise known as pot sticker.
We're using Napa cabbage.
We sprinkle salt on top of it
to help draw some of the water out
because we don't want too much moisture in the dumplings
because then it will be soggy and it'll fall apart.
I don't remember exactly the first time
we had guotie at home.
I just always remember whenever there was Chinese New Year
or a special occasion my mom would make the dumplings.
I just always remember them being an exciting part
because whenever there was something fun happening,
there'd be dumplings.
So, I would know that it would be an exciting time.
When I was a kid, some of my favorite times
were getting to spend time with my mom in the kitchen.
And we didn't have a lot of money when we were growing up,
but we always had enough food,
no matter how little money we had.
And I had a lot of allergies growing up as well,
and I would remember that my mom would make me special food.
So, to me, I will always remember food is love,
and if I can help cook and I can feed other people,
that's a way that I can show other people love.
- Hi, I'm Sanjana, and today I'm making Nepali momo.
Nepali momo is a kind of steamed dumpling
that's essentially Nepali street food.
So, I'm not from Nepal.
I'm actually South Indian, but my best friend, Nikita,
is Nepali and this recipe is actually her mom's.
So, the thing that really excites me about momo
is that the flavors in the filling
are super familiar to me.
I've grown up on Indian cooking.
My mom uses a lot of turmeric and a lot of gara masala
amongst other spices in a lot of her cooking,
so when I had momo that was packaged inside of this
really tiny type of dumpling,
it was really fun to be able to have that much flavor
that was just bite-sized and poppable.
It was just a little piece of home
inside this really tiny dumpling.
As opposed to soy sauce, Nepali momo use a chutney.
It just tastes so delicious
with the filling that's inside the momo.
Momo are definitely finger food, so use your hands,
pick up a momo, dip it in the sauce, and enjoy 'em.
- Hi, I'm Rie.
I'm making Japaneze gyoza dumpling today.
Gyoze is Japanese-style dumpling.
I got this recipe from my mom
and she eyeballs all of the ingredients,
which is a typical mom thing to do.
She used a lot of Nira chives.
I think that it's the secret for her gyoza.
Gyoza is one of the first dish
I learned how to cook from my mom.
The memory I have of making gyoza
is how fast my mom can fold them.
I would make one and she already made five.
It's been a while since I've made a gyoza with my mom,
but I bet she still makes them faster than me.
I usually pan fry gyoza.
After you line the gyoza in a pan,
you will add water to steam them.
I'm adding a tablespoon of flour into the water
so it will create extra crispy base.
We call this hane, which translate to wings.
This style of gyoza is really popular in Japan.
When I make gyoza, I usually end up making hundreds of them.
If freeze, it's great.
It's great for meal prep.
Every culture has their own version of dumplings.
Cooking connects people
and has a strong attachment to memory.
I hope after watching this,
it will bring back all the fun memories you had
with your family or friends,
or create new one with some dumplings.
- [Andrew] Oh, yes.
(relaxing music)